what are you doing I'm back to my room I
didn't do nothing
[Music]
welcome home what happened to your face
this little going away present from the
boys
chew out early you ain't on my reach boy
you're being awful hard on yourself we
can be forgiven
come on here ain't no point of keeping
it to secret one of our own shot with
his own pistol which we can't seem to
find
[Music]
turn on the car and trap
well I think I'll hold on to that same
too good
I will you tell me your little belongs
to you I shot him until he wasn't moving
no more no place you can go somewhere
safe but I'm gonna trust you you're
gonna have to trust me
what the hell is going on we need that
old place I'll explain everything later
all right I got your back
a woman came into the shelter little
girl that lady working there said she
found a pistol on her before she took
off running
I just need to know if Russell stayed
here with you tonight before last as far
as I know he was here
brother dead
I ain't looking to be another
[Music]
guy together by some sort of invisible
Road
just do the best you can for right now
you don't worry about tomorrow until it
comes
[Music]
lives of Whirlwind
we're all caught up in it